hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember so you don't have to and
welcome to wtr aka what's that real this
is a new segment where we look at a
nostalgic TV show that by all sense of
taste
probably should have existed there the
strain silly audible ideas that you
would never believe could fill an entire
season let alone 24 minutes but they did
and we're gonna look at whether or not
they were worth our time then and worth
our time now with that said I have a
little bit of a confession to make um
how did you come across Star Wars if
you're like most people you found out
from a friend a family member or even
the constant exposure from popular media
but that's not how I came across Star
Wars I came across Star Wars because I
saw it had he walks in it and I do it
had he walks in it because I saw the
spin-off movies and I saw the spin-off
movies because I played with the toys
and I played with the toys because I
watched he walks the car - yep not even
kidding this was my introduction to
start
it's about as backwards as you could
possibly get I had no idea who Luke
Skywalker Han Solo or Darth Vader were
but I could tell you with my proud
five-year-old dignity who wicked Tebow
and Letarte Oh a lot of Star Wars fans
are familiar with the cartoon droids the
spin-off show with c-3po and r2d2 but
very few people talked about this one
because fucking its Ewoks who the nerf
herder balls like Z walks well kids did
seeing how it actually ran longer than
droids by at least another season so
even though Joyce has more of a
following
Ewoks is the one that actually lasted
longer running from 1985 to 1986 he
watched chronicled the adventures of
well I guess the term now is younglings
in all the trouble and mayhem they get
into coming across various monsters and
creatures its main character is wicked
as seen from Return of the Jedi he
dreams of being a warrior and shouting
weird catch phrases like dengar
yeah I'm sure they'll catch out as well
as this how he has a friend who's a girl
so naturally being an 80s cartoon she
must be uh-oh the options back then if
you help others they'll help you someday
to be fair though there is another girl
character named Letarte who has a pretty
defined character at being self-centered
but cynically enjoyable and of course
Tibo a bumbling klutz who wants to be a
great wizard my mom will ground me for a
week how you may ask by using the
all-powerful Sun star an ancient device
of a Djinn this that does all sorts of
great magical stuff if used right and
when I say use riot I mean basically
just pointing it but pointing it really
passionately using Harry Potter logic
here the conflict of the show mostly
comes from various villains and Grinch
snot hair trying to capture the Sun star
and use its power for their own evil
ways thanks the light spirit locally
keeps the powerful Sun star now they say
this series is supposed to take place
before the Star Wars trilogy in fact the
last episode may be the only glimpse we
have of anything traditionally Star Wars
the Empire is following the theories of
a guy named doctor Rhaegar who believes
the Sun star can be used as a weapon the
Emperor himself has approved my
expedition the idea of the Empire
actually dedicating a mission to hunt he
wants just makes me laugh but then again
it's no different from them taking the
time to shut a cantina down the Empire
has closed us down it's weird to think
this is where the Empire discovered
their location to build their second
Death Star they were probably just like
look at these annoying embarrassments
nobody would ever want to come out here
let's set up our camp for destruction
thanks what that's it there are a few
things to take into account with this
being in the Star Wars universe
first of all magic exists here yeah not
the force magic they verbally clarify it
as that use your magic to cool
out here no you can technically make the
argument that may be what they call
magic the rest of the universe calls the
force but if that's so the Ewoks can
fucking use the force I mean I guess
it's open to anyone you know given the
midi-chlorians but doesn't that still
seem kind of strange what took Luke so
long to control and figure out as being
fucking master by chewed-up Care Bears
in fact with all the talk of the Sun
star being so powerful why didn't you
watch just use that to destroy the
Empire in the first place there's other
strange little additions one one usually
connect to this universe for example you
want to know Wicked's full name yeah
wicked actually has a full name the show
reveals it as wicked mystery Warwick
okay ignore the fact that's kind of cool
he's named after the actor who played
him in the movies were at Davis am I the
only one that finds a bizarre that you
want to have last names let alone middle
names were they're really just too many
wickets or Tebow's or block of lines
whatever held name you want makeup we
really needed last and middle names to
make things easier until I find out this
civilization has a postal service I'm
not seeing the reason you'll also notice
the show gets a little bit of a
retooling in between seasons a lot of
voice actors storylines and even designs
were changed more color and creativity
was given to both the Ewoks and the
other characters that inhabited the
universe making the series look less
like it was shot on the side of a
flaming shitbag most of the animation is
pretty decent but every once in a while
you get some of that ADEs children's
show laziness for example look at this
guy with the Empire he's supposed to be
human but he looks like Ron Perlman from
Beauty and the Beast there's another
scene where the Ewoks are supposed to
dress up like robots and oh my god
these fuckers knew exactly what they
were doing
you could change tipos name to dildo
after seeing that disguise key look they
even got legendary Batman storyteller
Paul Dini is one of the writers
oh boy what epic you sure we can attack
on this episode mom
I took the walk leaves to the hut of
horrors instead of the tumble bunny show
brilliant yeah this kind of gets down to
the essence of the show and why it
existed and that is it was obviously
meant for little kids as such both the
writing and style of the show pretty
much reflect that and as a show for
little kids goes it's the Heartless I
know a lot of people laugh that this
show even exists but honestly for what
it does it doesn't find the animation is
decent it has a lot of imagination to it
it's a totally serviceable product I
don't know if I recommend it to adults
or older children unless you just want
to see it for curiosity's sake but for
younger audiences it's not bad a part of
me almost wishes I quit hate it more as
they used to be the weakest part of the
Star Wars movies but there's really
nothing wrong with it for what it is
it's a cute spin-off that probably
didn't need to exist but doesn't do any
harm in being around either if you want
to see a Star Wars commercial tie-in
that's actually kind of innocent in its
approach this isn't a bad one to check
out
and like I said before it did introduce
me to Star Wars I mean how can a psyche
a spin-off show for doing that don't
push your luck I'm honest I sure could a
guy remembered so you don't have to
hey guys Doug Walker here we're having a
little contest actually something we
haven't done for a while we have a new
DVD coming out most likely in June and
it's sort of a best-of compilation of
the nostalgia critic stuff they seen
over the past few years and we are
looking for a cover artist we are
looking for a cover for the DVD to go on
there as of now we don't have an exact
title just being nostalgia critic
something so if you do want to work the
title and have nostalgia Craig there
that's fine just leave a little bit of
space for something else to go under
there uh and yeah this is one of those
fun times where you can just create your
own artwork you can throw in whatever
you want the kind of stuff that we
usually look for if you look at our past
artwork we sort of like the more Drew
Struzan big epic poster kind of stuff
Asli making it much bigger than really
is but that's always part of the joke so
be grand be big do whatever you want it
can be cartoony it can be realistic
there's lots of images of us on the
internet if you need pictures and there
will be characters from the show like
hyper fangirl and the devil and so on so
forth so please feel free to use them
and there as well as you want uh here is
the size that it has to be and in terms
of deadlines May 30th is the deadline
and the way it works is that you create
a deviantART account and you put your
picture on there the picture has to be
the size I said before and you pretty
much just send a link here just be sure
to put in your portfolio a deviantART
portfolio or just your portfolio site an
email you want to be contacted at and
your real name is just or than maybe you
want to go by and the winner will not
only get the artwork featured on the
front of the DVD but you'll also have a
link to your portfolio site on the
actual cover so will be on there for
everyone to see and you will also
get a hundred bucks sent to you as well
you know might as well get a little
something out of this and all the
runners-up will have a they'll have a
video in a nostalgic Greg at the end web
and establish our critics with your site
on there as well so it will also be a
lot of free promotion for you so if you
win that's great you get to be on the
cover the DVD your website promote it
again 100 bucks if you don't you still
have the possibility to be in one of
these videos or at leisure are working
one of the videos promoting your site so
again be sure to have your real name
linked to the deviantART picture and
also your portfolio site and it can be a
deviantART account that's fine remember
the deadline is May 30th and that's
about it guys go out there make some
great artwork you guys have always done
some great fan R in the past and we're
looking forward to seeing more take care